khady koïta i am of
senegalese origin has lived in europe for almost
forty years i am a member of this
group for the abolition of sexual mutilation
in france i was co-founder of
hornet networks in europe and i am
currently co-founder and  president
of the association la palette
i got involved in the fight against
female genital mutilation in
the 80s following the death of three
little girls in france deprived of lessons
because of excision is at that time
i was working against violence
done to women and 7 excision
came to disrupt all this work that we were
doing and myself having lived and suffered
domestic violence
I am committed to fighting against any
repression against any discrimination
against women
I think that to stop
female genital mutilation on  the
european continent the european union
must be able to ensure and encourage
all members to ratify the
istanbul convention signed in 2011 on
violence against women in general
and a section on prevention and
awareness training on
mutilation  female genitalia and also
that the European Union ensure that
funding for
associations is reduced and
increased so that associations
working in the field can
work in the long term with the
populations concerned on prevention
and awareness